thank you Sarah
and thank you to all of you and Siobhan
thank you very much for inviting me to
be here today to talk about Labor's
plans for our economy
a plan that can be summed up
in just one word
growth
I'm serious
that's it
now in the job that I'm doing you get to
see a lot of the country
you're on the road every week
so I know we have enormous problems in
our economy and our communities
but honestly it's obvious to me
that the root cause of so many of our
challenges is a lack of economic growth
now I know what a lot of people in
Westminster say about growth
they say it's an abstract concept
doesn't resonate doesn't connect with
people's lives I don't accept that
growth is higher wages
growth is stronger communities
growth is thriving businesses it's more
vibrant High streets less poverty more
opportunity warmer homes healthier food
better jobs
it's public services that are well
funded it's holidays meals out
more cash in your pocket and an end to
the suffocating cost of living crisis
our ticket to win the race for the
future and the biggest single thing we
need to lift our sights raise our
Ambitions get our hope our confidence
and our future back
and and look
if we're elected
we'll approach this with a new mindset
a new purpose
and a new approach to governing
we will be driven by five clear missions
measurable missions
missions that embrace the challenge of
clear accountability
set a focused Direction and bring the
whole country together to move us
forward
so our economic mission
our goal on growth the target will put
in the next Labor Manifesto is this
in the next Parliament Britain will have
the highest sustained growth in the G7
it's ambitious I know that
and I don't make any apologies for that
the highest sustained growth in the G7
that should draw a sharp intake of
breath
and yes I am aware of the headwinds
we've got to navigate our way through
Revolutions in technology in energy in
medicine and with an aging Society even
in Who We Are
climate change is a recipe for Global
instability
the shape of power in the world is
changing
there's a war on our continent
and because of all of this we must
square up to a New Economic era
where the old assumptions on labor or
energy on traded Goods no longer apply
no doubt about it all your company risk
registers will be long I know that
but the way I see it
there are also opportunities to be
seized new markets to open up
a more prosperous future that can be won
take Net Zero
and the green industries of tomorrow
a new Global Market of up to one
trillion pounds
but of course
a competitive market
where countries all around the world not
just in the US are setting a new tempo
a dash for green growth and we've got to
be on the pitch
this is the biggest opportunity to make
our country work for working people that
we've had in decades and it's no good
carping from the sidelines
holding on to an outdated economic logic
as the rest of the world eats our lunch
some nation is going to design medicines
personalized to match our unique DNA
why not this one
some Nation will create the first
generation of quantum computers
why not us
some Nation will lead the world in
offshore wind why not Britain
I'll tell you one reason why not
our planning system
people running the National Grid
recently you know what they said to me
they said
if we want to get anywhere near our
goals on Net Zero
we need to build more infrastructure in
the next seven years than we have in the
last 30.
let that sink in
and yet
what's the average time it takes to
build an offshore wind farm
13 years
an entiretory government
and now house building crashing to a
record low
onshore wind
just two turbines built last year
critical infrastructure like hs2 built
more slowly and expensively because of
the red tape
and the net result
an economy stuck in second gear a doom
Loop of low growth low productivity and
high taxes
a generation on its hopes an entire
future blocked
by those who more often than not enjoy
the secure homes and jobs that they're
denying to others
the evidence couldn't be clearer
there are 38 countries in the oecd
and we are the second worst when it
comes to the effectiveness of our
planning system
just think
some people call our problems
the productivity puzzle
we know the problems
we've just got to show a bit more bottle
to fix them
I mean I listened to the prime minister
at the dispatch books recently
bearing his head in the sand on this
issue playing to the Tory gallery
that's not serious
you can't be serious about raising
productivity
about improving the supply side capacity
of our economy about arresting our
economic decline
without a plan for wind farms the
Laboratories the warehouses and the
homes this country so desperately needs
that doesn't work for Britain
it doesn't work for business it doesn't
work for growth
and I won't accept it
because there's nothing that reeks more
of decline
than the idea that this country no
longer knows how to build things
so mark my words we will take on
planning reform
we will bring back local housing targets
we'll streamline the process for
National infrastructure projects and
Commercial development
and we'll remove the veto used
by big landowners to stop shovels
hitting the ground
tough choices
but the right choices
choices we make with our eyes wide open
we choose the builders not the blockers
the future not the past renewal not
decline we choose growth
and there's a bigger lesson here
in this new more volatile economic era
businesses need a government that gets
involved
there's no future in a stand aside state
that won't deliver the stability and the
certainty
won't manage the tide of change that's
coming
it's it's simple really every business
in this room
has a strategy for growth
a nation needs one too
and that's not a return to the mistakes
of the past
we've got to get over that hangover
in every one of our competitors
industrial policy is the bread and
butter of responsible economic
management
about what the state does
not how big it is
how it can support businesses of all
sizes to innovate and grow
can bring in the creative Brilliance of
our scientists and universities
can work with trade unions and bring you
all together to unleash the potential of
our strengths our Cutting Edge
technology sector
our superpower Services life sciences
that save lives
it's a shared undertaking that is not
State Control
or pure free markets
but a genuine partnership sleeves rolled
up working in the national interests
this is fundamental to my politics
I believe in the power of dynamic
government
but I also believe in the Brilliance of
British businesses
and I've changed my labor party to
reflect that
we're not just a pro-business party
we're a party that is proud of being
pro-business that respects the
contribution profit makes to jobs to
growth and to our tax base
gets that working people want success as
well as support
understands that robust private sector
growth is the only way we pay our way in
the world
but look I've also got to be clear
we hold our hand out in Partnership
but we do it with an uncompromising
purpose
the purpose that shapes everything we
want to achieve in government all five
of our national missions
that is to change this country
so it once again respects serves and
delivers for working people
we're going to tip the scales away from
the vested interests that have held our
businesses and our economy back for too
long the blockers the stiflers those who
are comfortable with tourist stagnation
and failure
and they're not going to give up without
a fight
that's not how change happens
but these past 13 years
what working people have been through
what businesses have been through
nearly record numbers of small
businesses going under
and every one of those a personal
tragedy
an ambition
a dream an investment in a better future
gone
all this
it has to be a turning point
Britain needs a new business model
and changing a business model is hard
you know huh
it requires Mission purpose
determination
openness and partnership absolutely
but it also requires hard choices
so I want to set out five priorities
very quickly I promise
five key economic shifts that will
underpin our mission for growth building
blocks if you like of our strategy to
lead Britain out of its low growth
high-tax doomloop
shift one
from chaos to certainty
the rock of economic stability that must
underpin everything that we do
this is why you need a government that
gets involved that takes active
strategic decisions
it's the only way to provide real
certainty in this era
investors in this country need a clear
framework that holds for the long term
with policies that are always fully
costed
fiscal rules sound and followed
rigorously
institutions
respected not bypassed
all our aspirations must be built on
this
and don't doubt us for a second
but honestly
the way I see it
stability is the least the British
people should expect
Britain needs certainty yes
but also change
so shift to
we must move the economy that holds
potential
to one that unlocks it everywhere
communities need to be in charge of
their economic destiny
growth comes from the Grassroots
and it must provide secure well-paid
jobs in all areas of the country
Britain is far too centralized and this
hurts us economically
a politics that Hoards power
goes hand in hand with an economy that
holds potential I'm utterly convinced by
this
so we will give the communities and
nations of this country the right powers
to drive private sector growth
and to get their High streets growing
again new powers for councils to take
over empty retail units
and yes we will level the playing field
with online warehouses we will scrap and
replace business rates
shift three
Britain must go from lagging to Leading
must get on the pitch in science
technology green growth and the
opportunities of tomorrow
that's why we need a reformed planning
system
need a modern industrial strategy
need a more powerful British Business
Bank that will help scale businesses new
and old
and why we need a government that won't
sit on the sidelines
that will invest for train people for
trout in finance for scale up Supply
chains for reform procurement for has a
plan for the dream jobs and cheaper
energy of the future
that will use every tool at our disposal
to make sure Britain becomes a
superpower in green growth
shift four
we've got to stop creating insecure work
and thinking
job done
nobody here would be happy with a job
that didn't provide security or respect
so neither should we be happy with an
economic model that demands this from
working people
and that isn't fair to businesses doing
the right thing
this is absolutely critical for us
we don't see a labor market that locks
in low pay and productivity as Beyond
reform we see it as an opportunity to
finally make work pay for Millions
that's why we'll offer more flexible
skills funding
a reformed apprenticeship Levy
a modernized child care system
and a new deal on employment rights that
we know the Tories will attack in the
usual way
there isn't a single advance for workers
in this country that they haven't
resisted
but we are here to restore the labor
party to its purpose
of serving working people
and we think categorically
that this will be good for growth
shift five
our economy must become more resilient
to Global shocks
and we must be more open to global trade
this cannot be a choice that might work
in a seminar room or the political Arena
but it doesn't work for businesses
trying to export
so we've got to use the levers like
procurement creatively
nurture more resilient Supply chains and
fix the brexit deal
we've got to project a more open stance
to the world
believe me I know how important this is
Global standing has to be earned not
taken for granted
nobody owes us a future
when the big questions are asked around
the conference tables all around the
world
where do we put our money
where do our jobs go where does our
investment in a better future go we have
to make sure the answer that comes back
to a resounding white not Britain
that's what our mission is about
that's why we need more growth and I
want everyone here to know
we are ready to take on that challenge
and we will deliver
I know because I see more and more
people lining up shoulder to shoulder
with labor
businesses crying out for a government
that backs them to grow
working people desperate for an economy
that puts their interest first
everyone from scientists to pipefitters
data Engineers to plumbers
a union of the willing impatient to
build a better Britain
that's the businesses the builders the
British public
together
no less than the backbone of our economy
the backbone of our country
in Partnership
the backbone of our country United in
their hope for a better future
with that backbone supporting us we can
unlock Britain's untapped opportunities
we can renew our country from go for
growth and build a better Britain thank
you very much
[Applause]
thank you
thank you very much indeed we've got a
number of questions starting with
um some questions from the media and I
think first of those is romley from ITV
romley they are
hi there does one of the tough choices
you refer to include building on the
green belt and is that really the answer
to Britain's do England's uh housing
woes
let me be clear about what our ambition
is here and that's what I meant when I
said in my speech that we back the
builders not the blockers
the aspiration to own your own home is
real it's a dream for so many people and
it's more than a dream it's actually
about security
and I know from my own upbringing that
although we didn't have a lot of money
we did own our own home with a mortgage
and that meant there was a security that
went with it and that dream
is being killed
it's been killed by a government that's
taken down the targets for housing and
everybody in this room will know that
means that building of houses is likely
to drop now to the lowest level since
the second world war and so the dream
the aspiration of owning your own home
is going to be killed and we need to do
something about that romiley and what we
need to do is put the targets back up
but if that's all we do we'll just go
back to where we were at the tail end of
last year when we weren't building
enough homes so we need to do more than
that and fix planning
and also have development corporations
as a vehicle for building homes and when
I say fixed planning what I mean by that
is giving more power to local areas to
direct where housing will be built
um and that does mean uh decisions about
the green belt now don't get me wrong
just like everybody else in this room I
want to protect the green belt I value
our Countryside but this is about
choosing where development takes place
there is already building on the Green
Belt the question is do local areas have
sufficient control over where that
happens and how that happens and an
example that I would give is some
building of houses in the southeast of
England
where the choice was between a playing
field and a car park
and the car park was technically on the
green belt and the playing field wasn't
I'd say the houses were built on the
playing field not the car park we've got
to take better decisions than that so we
want to give power to local areas to
have much more control over where they
build and with development corporations
to put those houses up but that is tough
choices and it's tough choices about the
green belt of course we want protection
of the green belt but we also want to
recognize there is building on the Green
Belt but it needs to be on the right bit
of it in the car park not the playing
field
um and
um that is a the sort of tough decision
that this government has backed away
from and the net result is we won't have
the houses built that will help people
in their dream to own their own home
thank you romiley I think we're going to
get to cure him at the guardian next
thank you very much Karen Stacy from the
guardian and just to follow up on
romolly's question you talk about giving
more powers to local councils are you
also willing to override local councils
who don't do enough to build who perhaps
block developments that you think could
help ease the housing crisis and the
second one on housing FMA you talk about
reform to the leaseholder system you
talk about ending lease holding on new
developments but you haven't gone
further and said that you want to end
leasehold on existing buildings and
allow existing leaseholders away out of
their current contracts would you go
further and and say that as well on the
question of local authorities we want to
put the targets up we want them to be
real and we want them to be achieved we
want to work with local authorities on
that give them the power to do that very
often local authorities tell me that
amongst the problems is that it's the
landowners and the developers who
actually choose where the housing is and
the local Authority can't direct that so
give them more powers and you to unlock
some of the blockage in the system
reforming the planning system along the
way so we do want to give those Powers I
would also be open to looking at whether
this can be done on a pan local
Authority basis because I think amongst
the problems we've got is that this is
all very piece male very very localized
and actually if you look at the
infrastructive look at the way we want
to grow the economy it would make sense
in my view to club together local
authorities in certain areas of the
country so that together they could plan
the housing that could be built in the
best place an example would be a long
train lines to build the businesses and
the communities to feed and support the
infrastructure that we desperately need
which again is a major driver of growth
and when it comes to house building I've
spoken about the aspiration of people to
have their own home which is very very
real but also house building is a route
to economic growth both the building and
the other aspects that it can have goes
that it can unlock along the way or on
leasehold reform
um
firstly I think the 2020 law commission
recommendations are about right and we
would Implement them and I think it's a
crying shame that the government having
said that it accepted those
recommendations on leasehold has now
backed away because it says it's run out
of Road run out of ideas hasn't got time
to do it so Michael Gove as that said he
understands the Injustice and why the
system doesn't work but now he's not
going to do the second bit of what he
promised so we will pick that up and we
will do that and that does mean
reforming existing leaseholds and
following the recommendation about new
leaseholds thank you Kieran and I think
we've got Jack from City am Jack
um lots of businesses room are Keen to
invest in the UK economy but they're
quite hesitant to do so as a result of
all the tax and spending policies we've
seen scrapped over the last couple of
years but the present government are
just wondering what more assurances you
can give to the people in this room that
labor will create an environment to
allow Investments of thrive in the UK
and boost growth I think it's vital that
we create the circumstances for
investment to thrive it's absolutely
vital we will not get growth unless we
do that I've spoken to no end of
investors
um some in this room some in the UK some
across the globe and they are very clear
with me
that until this proper stability
uncertainty and long-term planning and
strategy from the government is very
difficult to create the circumstances to
invest and you know we often think that
the idea that we've had four chancellors
or four budgets in the last 12 months is
is politically funny it makes for a good
cartoon it's hopeless when it comes to
investment they are not the conditions
investors who tell me they are
withholding the investment they might
otherwise put into our country because
the conditions aren't right so stability
has to be the key to that and of course
you know you touch on high tax why have
we got such a high tax regime in my view
it's because we've got low growth
low growth low growth low growth leading
to high tax highest tax as you know
since the second world war we've got to
break out of that cycle that is about
certainty stability having a plan for
growth using the partnership that we can
put together with businesses we want to
partner with business we want to be
clear what the government does and what
business does and we want to take tough
decisions like changing the planning
laws lots of business said to me what's
stopping me moving forward is it takes
too long the example I give about wind
turbines is just an example what should
take two or three years taking 13 years
there are many examples that people
around this room will have in their own
sector and we've got for too long we've
been cowed by this we had a government
that's just not prepared to take the
tough decisions got to take those tough
decisions thank you very much I think
Aisha I'm now joining you for questions
and then we're going to take questions
from the audience I look forward to